bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue le débat a déjà commencé comme vous
pouvez peut-être l'entendre on est ravi
de vous retrouver pour ce dernier numéro
de la semaine avec quatre sujets qu'on
découvre comme toujours en images
on parlera des gilet jaune bien sûr ça
se passe demain on aurait dénombré 1000
500 actions différentes qui serait prévu
pour bloquer le pays protester contre
les taxes sur les carburants
mais est-ce que c'est dangereux est ce
qu'il ya des risques de dérapage
d'affrontements on en parlera et puis on
parlera aussi des lobbys pourquoi le
cacher c'est la couverture du figaro
magazine de ce week-end c'est aussi un
vrai sujet sociétal et politique faut-il
avoir peur des lobbys ou sont ils un mal
nécessaire dans une démocratie moderne
on en parlera n'en parlerons aussi du
maquereau machine qui semble être le
sport à la mode
ça fait quinze jours trois semaines que
ce mouvement est presque systématique
peut être en fait on trop eh bien vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez et puis
on s'arrêtera sur ce tableau de david
hockney
le peintre britannique dont études dont
une oeuvre a été vendu 80 millions
d'euros 81 même pour être précis
cette semaine ce qui en fait le tableau
le plus cher d'un artiste vivant est-ce
que ça les vaut ben on vous interrogera
tous les quatre sur ce sujet nos quatre
invités bonsoir ferghana ziari ravis de
vous accueillir vous êtes analyste en
politiques publiques
vous êtes notamment un collaborateur de
l'iref qui était un think tank de
tendance plutôt libérale on va dire ou
même clairement libéral mathieu soupière
et là aussi bonsoir vous êtes membre
associé de la fondation jean jaurès qui
est pas tout à fait sur le même créneau
on va dire que social une fondation
sociale démocrate que ça tout à fait
tout cela suivez comme tel
voilà et vous avez été le conseiller du
maire yamile conneries quand elle était
ministre du travail
olivier ravanello et là aussi bon soir
olivier vous est le cofondateur le
président du média en ligne explicite
point info et nos internautes nous
connaissent parce que vous avez aussi
été l'un des patrons d'i télé et hervé
nathan est là aussi bon soit vous êtes
directeur adjoint de la rédaction de
marianne marianne qui cette semaine met
en couverture ce peuple qui pue le
diesel
peut-être que c'est le peuple des gilet
jaune ça m'a l'air d'être une certitude
vu la photo qui illustre votre
couverture et justement on va en parler
des gilet jaune c'est donc demain que va
se dérouler ce mouvement sur lequel on
ne sait pas grand-chose il paraît qu'il
y aurait mille 500 actions prévues et
puis il paraît aussi ça ce sont les
services de renseignements qu'ils nous
le disent que huit franciliens cinq
hommes et trois femmes âgés de 27 à 35
ans serait à l'origine de ce mouvement
et nous aucun engagement militant connu
mais simplement une passion commune
ce sont les rassemblements automobile
alors faut-il craindre les affrontements
les dérapages
écoutez on n'en sait rien à vrai dire
mais le pouvoir est relativement en
alerte
écoutez le premier ministre il était
aujourd'hui dans l'essonne
il n'est pas complètement détendu on
peut manifester mais bloquer un pays
alors que les services d'urgence peuvent
avoir besoin de circuler alors que tout
un chacun peut avoir besoin de circuler
demain n'est évidemment pas acceptable
nous serons donc très attentif très
concentré très vigilant pour faire en
sorte que la liberté de manifester soit
respecté mais que la liberté de
circulation soit également 40e' hervé
nathan est ce que il a un caractère
inquiétant ce mouvement il ya un pic et
il a un caractère inquiétant pour les
pouvoirs établis à la fois gouvernement
devant les conseillers de l'elysée
disent oh là là surtout on fait pas le
fier devant ce moment là on l'a d'abord
on a du mal à les prendre et on
comprends pas bien cette année sur
internet puis c'est la première fois
qu'on voit vraiment un mouvement né sur
internet aboutir les mobilisations dans
la rue
à vrai dire ce l'elysée qui le château
qui pensaient parler directement aux
français par dessus les corps
intermédiaires et encore quelques mois
on va dire que tout à leur dire accéder
que c'est fini là se retrouve confronté
à une demande sociale à une contestation
qui là qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
mal à appréhender
alors quand je dis y'a pas que le yap a
continué un pack elysées il ya aussi
semble-t-il certaine manière les
blocages ont déjà commencé dans l'est et
dans les têtes c'est à dire que quand on
voit que les sociétés d'autoroutes une
société d'autoroute qui en europe
commander aux automobilistes ne pas
venir sur les autoroutes samedi on ne
sait pas ce qu'il peut se passer
il ya une grande chaîne de supermarchés
qui a dit à ses clients ne venait pas
samedi on ne sait pas ce qui peut se
passer et c'est d'une certaine manière
le blocage a déjà les déjà dans les
têtes c'est bien dans les têtes des dix
ont des super structure de ce pays et
donc d'une certaine façon les gilet
jaune ont déjà perturbé la vie de la vie
du pays ou moins tard anticipations
après est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
vrais des vraies perturbations ou
d'ailleurs par exemple d'ailleurs des
violences moi je n'en suis pas persuadé
parce que je pense
de deux choses l'une soit le mouvement
il est vraiment in organisé et moi je ne
me souviens pas qu'on ait vu des vraies
violences or avec ce que ça veut dire de
confrontation avec les forces de police
par exemple sans qu'ils aient des
organisations par exemple les gilet
rouge les gillou et part dans les
bonnets rouges en est on des bonnets
rouges pardon en 2000 en 2010 qu'en 2013
la sépaq toutefois de laisser des
comptes et 3 testait il y avait des
organisations il y avait en son sein des
organisations comme par exemple les
organisations pays d'agriculteurs qui
étaient des spécialistes de
l'affrontement avec la police
je veux dire c'est les agriculteurs et
des organisations d'agriculteurs qui ont
fait descendre les poteaux parce qu'ils
savaient le faire si ça va mener le
purin et sa venue et plus ils saluent
s'enflammer ça ça demande de la
coordination de l'organisation
moi je parie que si c'est vraiment d in
organisé qui seront là demain je pense
qu'ils n'iront au seuil d'une peau n'ont
pas la possibilité non pas
l'organisation pour faire ça voilà
olivier ravanello 7
cette manifestation à l'aide d'une
nature assez original hervé nathan le
disait eric zemmour dans le fig mag
d'aujourd'hui la décrit comme une
rébellion de man ans sans perspective
politique
mais ajoutent-ils c'est d'autant plus
grave c'est à dire que comme comme il
n'y a pas d'organisation ça peut partir
dans tous les sens sa part déjà dans
tous les sens mais ça m'inquiète le plus
pur
la nature du débat public ce qui va se
passer samedi je ne crois pas que je ne
crois pas ou je crois peu importe et
jason n'a pas la non mais si oui parce
qu'on n'est pas là pour lire dans la
boule de cristal et que l'on sait rien
donc évitons de dire des bêtises
ce qui est sûr de mon point de vue c'est
que c'est dangereux pour le débat public
parce qu'on est dans un dans un vrai
mouvement démagogique
au sens littéral du terme et que on va
voir demain des gens qui vont mettre le
gilet jaune mais la question c'est de
savoir mais on fait quoi une fois qu'on
a sur le dos et là il ya aucune réponse
et que par définition un mouvement
politique qui rentre dans le débat
public dont on a fait un acteur du débat
public puisque nous en parlons tous et
puis on essaye de voir s'il ya des
raisons de ce qu'on lui disait ou pas
par définition à un projet collectif a
quelque chose à proposer à la société
avec laquelle on va être d'accord on va
pas être d'accord et là y'a rien à
proposer puisque il est tellement
disparates que vous avez à la fois une
mobilisation du côté des insoumis des
anticapitalistes des petits chefs
d'entreprises des gens qui sont attachés
à leur pouvoir d'achat des policiers qui
sont mal traités des retraités de tout
le monde et le seul mot d'ordre si on
n'est pas content mais on n'est pas
content ça fait pas de la politique
fayard et que quand on peut le voir vous
êtes vous parti pendant de ce mouvement
pourrait manifester demain pour voir
oui sony parce que non oui sans doute
parce que vous vous disiez qu'il ya pas
de mot d'ordre je pense que là tandis
que farhad à essayer de bloquer le
plateau c'est totalement cas donnant une
nouvelle vie tout par ajoie
je vais trouver la vérité bien avec le
même papillon et zola par dire qu'il n'y
a pas de mot d'ordre est donné c'est ne
pas avoir compris l'essence de cette
mobilisation c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya une exaspération
vis-à-vis de la fiscalité c'est pas le
prix du carburant qui est en cause
beaucoup de rédactions commenté le prix
du carburant la réalité c'est le poids
des prélèvements obligatoires qui
exaspère aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
français moi je fais le pari que si nous
étions dans un pays si je suis content
le obligatoire c'est pas vous conseillé
aux étudiants dans mes draps fait dix
ans dans un pays qui était beaucoup
moins fiscalisés moi je fais le pari que
cette fiscalité écologique quoi qu'on en
pense ce serait beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus
accepter or on vit aujourd'hui il faut
le rappeler parce que le vide
visiblement beaucoup de commentateurs
comme vous ne le comprennent pas on vit
dans le pied le plus fiscalisé du monde
on vit dans le pays le plus fiscalisé
dumas après je suis à gauche
forcément ça je le tronc pro forma non
mais j'ai deux mains par mois je suis
moi je dit surpris par sa survie à la
surprise des commandes des commentateurs
fait que la personne c'est un côté de
vous samedi n'en aura peut-être rien à
faire de la fiscalité et des
prélèvements obligatoires elle aura
quand même un gilet jaune puis on aura
encore un autre qui on aura rien à faire
de ce que le deuxième lui est venue
faire et qui va aussi se mobiliser c'est
juste que je dis qui met donc fin à
l'elysée tout ça très bien mais au final
on fait quoi
au départ tout ça est née d'une taxe
supplémentaire sur le nez ou le diesel
donc j'ai vraiment c'est un prélèvement
obligatoire qui ont plus musical et un
moment compliqué que c'est une taxe
grotesque puisque le diesel aujourd'hui
ne peut plus ne pollue pas plus que la
voiture n'a eu ce débat et encore deux
semaines ici même et que ce sont les
diesels d'avant 2005 qui polluent
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui pollue dans une
voiture le savez ou gelée a pris elle
l'expliqué demain sur explicite pour
moitié une voiture pollue à cause de ces
plaquettes de frein et à cause de ses
pneus pas parce qu'il sort du pot
d'échappement on est dans un des parcs
est complètement démagogique sur
l'écologie mais il n'empêche
demain il va d'avoir des gens qui sont
contre les prélèvements fiscaux quand
les petits salaires pour l'écologie coût
pour la petite entreprise tout le monde
et au final expliqué dans la politique
menée avec ce genre j'ai quand même
centré sur la fiscalité et encore une
fois c'est pas quelque chose qui est
surprenant je le dis en compte dans le
pays je le répète le plus disque alizés
du monde il faut le rappeler le plus
fiscalisé du monde avec le salarié moyen
qui est exproprié hauteur de 56 % de ses
revenus une contestation de cette
ampleur était inévitable si j'étais une
mauvaise langue
si j'étais en contrôle infligée il
faudrait des locutions raison que je
rappellerai que les contestations
fiscale dans l'histoire il y en a eu
pour moins que ça les six si j'étais
vraiment de mauvaise foi je vous dirai
aussi que les américains n'ont pas
attendu d'être taxés à 50 6% pour faire
sécession de la couronne britannique que
les révolutionnaires français de 89
n'ont pas attendu d'être taxés à 50 6%
pour pour contester la monarchie donc il
ya vraiment un niveau de prélèvements
obligatoires qui aujourd'hui est
excessif qu'il faut nécessairement à
interroger et encore une fois je suis
sûr que quoi qu'on pense encore une fois
de la fiscalité écologique
si on tombe à pic et est beaucoup plus
sobre sur le
les gens ne seraient pas aussi affecté
vis-à-vis des atteintes portées à
l'encontre de leur pouvoir d'achat
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on
peut légitimement envisager on va passer
la parole à mathieu ce cas mais avant on
va la passer au français partant de
cette production un peu pompeuse pour
vous parler d'un sondage qui est paru ce
matin dans le figaro page aux hawks à
del se consulter selon lequel 74 % de
nos compatriotes trouve que le mouvement
des gilet jaune de demain et justifier
avoir un prêt va coûter les français
nous écoutons un français n'ont commandé
vendredi soir est donc presque week-end
j'ai une bonne humeur et j'ai envie dans
le vert un peu à moitié plein d'abord
pour dire ce que la question posée c'est
celle de l'inquiétude nourrit face à ce
mouvement qui pourrait déboucher sur des
débordements etc
il est toujours en fait positif de
constater qu'un mouvement social
s'exprime émergent
c'est le propre des démocraties on
l'oublié un peu vous faites il ya des
tas de régime où on ne peut pas
manifester cette façon là et c'est
problématique
au contraire chez nous finalement il
peut y avoir une opposition politique
syndical et même populaire qui exprime
son mécontentement de façon totalement
libre c'est plutôt une bonne chose
deuxième chose il se trouve j'ai pas lu
la note des rg enfin j'ai vu qu'on en
parle est effectivement que à
l'initiative de ce mouvement il y a huit
internautes à 8 personnes qui ont fait
le buzz en fait à partir d'internet à
partir des réseaux sociaux
alors il ya eu même coagulation de
plusieurs petites choses
en tout état de cause c'est un vrai
mouvement spontané né ou relayées en
tout cas grâce aux réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux ça produit parfois le
pire mais ça peut aussi produire de la
mobilisation citoyenne et c'est pas si
pire
ensuite sur le contenu du mouvement oui
je rejoins ce que disait olivier
ravanello l'instant il ya la question du
débouché politique quand il n'ya pas de
débouchés politiques ou quand ya
éventuellement une tonalité à ce
mouvement social qui peut parfois être
un tout petit peu factieuses c'est à
dire on va marcher sur l'elysée on a
entendu quelques propos qui acquit
alfroid c'est un peu l'oreille ça
effectivement c'est inquiétant quand on
voit que l'extrême droite elle même fait
un bougé elle s'est toujours tenue très
éloignées en fait des mouvements sociaux
populaires de cet ordre là elle
accompagne volontiers le mouvement dans
une grande convergence et une grande
instrumentaliser instrumentalisation
politique qui va de mélenchon à l'open
en passant par par wauquiez tout ça
effectivement pose question alors
effectivement tu disais à l'instant que
ça correspondait à un niveau de
prélèvements obligatoires inédit dans
l'histoire il ya toujours eu des
jacqueries il ya toujours eu des
contestations populaires face à l'impôt
quel qu'ait été le mouvement de
prélèvements obligatoires donc je ne
sais pas si on peut dire que le niveau
est aujourd'hui excessif certes il est
beaucoup plus élevé qu'il n'a jamais été
mais ça correspond à une socialisation
en fait des ressources pour se garantir
des services publics venaient d'arriver
les mains je suis désolé je vois la
trentaine de jeux et city qui laisse
moins terminer deux choses il ya quand
même deux éléments par rapport à ceux
qui s'expriment dans ce mouvement un
premier qui est un rejet du pouvoir et
des élites qui est probablement d'autant
plus marqué que la présidence de macron
jusqu'à présent des notes par une forme
d'arrogance que toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion mentionne et puis deuxième
chose les prélèvements obligatoires ils
ont quand même baissé pour quelques-uns
n'ont pas les riches n'ont pas les très
riches comme disait françois hollande
mais les ultra riches comme l'a constaté
une note de la fondation jean jaurès il
y a peu de temps donc je doute que tout
le monde porte un gilet jaune demain les
ultra-riches dans ce pays ont bénéficié
depuis un an de la politique fiscale
menée beaucoup au mouvement 5 étoiles
combat qui attend dé moi je dis on voit
comment il a fini en italique années de
gloire
moi j'aurais dit joint les agneaux
est-il de leno les juniors on lui
permettant une nouvelle ça ne ressemble
pas au moins cinq étoiles ça ne
ressemble à rien là je suis d'accord
avec les avez-vous olivier c'est que ça
ne ressemble à rien mais est ce que
c'est parce que ça ne ressemble à rien
et qui a pu y aurait pas de débouché
politique que c'est pas un vrai
mouvement parce que le prendre là milena
moi ça dit quelque chose de vraiment
important
soit c'est juste la manipulation et puis
rien du tout mais j'ai passé mon temps à
lire j'ai pas finir non mais
j'appréhende la gestion générant police
george ii parle normal
je n'ai pas cette intention et je n'ai
pas cette prétention là parce qu'il ya
une prétention alors pour le coup des
jeunes italiennes et celles à essayer de
guy inbar
alors là précis mais s'y habitue soyez
oui aujourd'hui c'est bien mais ça ça
change un peu la nature ça serait sympa
votre nature profonde sur des scellés
contenant johnny par exemple le vase
pour y être alors je vais citer g / t un
autre un autre éditorialiste de la
presse de la db des médias parisiens sur
france inter on a eu droit à une
dissertation sur le fait qu' un peu
comme vous il n'y a pas de débouchés
politiques qui serait incohérent le
mouvement serait incohérent et
antidémocratique c'est facile de dire ça
depuis saint siège à paris qui arrive
d'abord ça arrive que les mouvements
voilà c'est harry ne s'est pas là mais
tout sur quelle base on peut dire
incohérent d'accord antidémocratique
parce qu'à une protestation c'est comme
ça c'est incohérent de dire que parce
qu'on serait on serait antidémocratique
parce qu'on serait incohérent par
ailleurs alors sur la question des
prélèvements obligatoires
bonne question effectivement une partie
de l'un des soubassements de ce
mouvement c'est effectivement refus de
la fiscalité trop forte
mais alors que pour le coup moi ce que
je mets en cause c'est la manière
technocratique et cela je voudrais
terminer vous voudrez amis parce que
c'est peut-être un peu subtil qui est à
terme être en cause selon moi c'est la
manière technocratique dont on décide
dans un pays où la fiscalité est
effectivement élevé parce qu'il ya
énormément de services publics à
financer quand même notamment parce que
le principal des prélèvements
obligatoires c'est quand même la maladie
et la vieillesse un fou quoi vous
commencez par le dire donc c'est pour
les vieux et les malades
donc si on veut ne plus avoir de vieux
non mais sans vérification
fini les mêmes catégories sont hors
d'elles mêmes catégories enfants sont
hors d'elle et c'est le pays de laisser
lever via le wan d'impôts dans les 38 de
la deuxième les esprits de qualité de la
france des états il n'y a pas
d'infrastructures etc est un peu
caricatural catégories populaires et
rurales sont vachement content tu en ce
moment aux états unis malgré le taux
d'impôt mourey avait quasiment moitié
moins de celui de la france
des prélèvements obligatoires ils sont à
30% p o ça va bien aux états unis pour
les catégories populaires ils ont l'air
satisfaite pourquoi ils ont voté trump à
votre avis parce qu'elle trouvait que
franchement c'était formidable leur
avenir parce qu'il passait les un point
là webb a peut-être pas là pour
apprendre pourtant ils sont encore à
lyon il en faut encore moins parce qu'on
n'arrive pas on crève
donc le problème qui se pose c'est
peut-être le problème des revenus plutôt
que celui des impôts
c'est drôle parce qu'il ya voir les
impôts c'est peut-être de l'europe
attention un coup après un an de façon
relativement injuste mais il a messi
avait tout l'intérêt d'un point de vue
c'est qu'on compare des filets jaunes à
long terme et sur quelles politiques
macroéconomiques pour le 21e siècle et
c'est tout à fait intéressant je foutais
22e et ça c'est vendre à peut-être pas
le temps parce que c'est le week end
arrive je donne la parole à nos
internautes à babineau qui nous divise
l'idée de départ est plutôt bonne mais
les gilets jaunes ont été récupérés par
plusieurs formations politiques
et puis nicole qui est sur la même ligne
que ferghana ziari et qui nous dit c'est
l'accumulation de tous ses impôts et
taxes qui met les gens dans la rue on
parle d'un autre sujet de groupes de
pression mais cela parfaitement
organisée on les appelle les lobbys en
bon français il se trouve qu'ils font la
couverture du figaro magazine parce
qu'on a consacré un dossier intéressant
à ce sujet mais c'est pas uniquement
pour ça que je vous propose est d'en
parler c'est aussi parce qu'on a on ya
une thèse dans ce papier qui est que
peut-être les lobbys sont utiles dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui ils sont organisés
ils sont visibles et que peut-être que
c'est mieux que d'avoir des gens qui
tirent file en douce des valises de
billets mathieu souk rs que dans une
démocratie moderne dans lesquels louis à
des groupes de pression il faut pas
mieux qui s'exprime dès lors que c'est
ouvertement les lobbys c'est un peu
comme la choucroute parfois c'est bon
parfois c'est moins bon parfois c'est
réussi en l'occurrence j'ai lu avec
beaucoup que j'ai dévoré le figaro
magazine comme chaque semaine
vu votre papier avec beaucoup d'intérêt
c'est très intéressant la question des
lobbys ce n'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau on
on a souvent même parfois dans la
pression dit un marronnier on a parlé de
tous les lobbys qui ont pu exister à
travers l'histoire
en l'occurrence j'étais très intéressé
par votre papier mais quand même frappé
par un rapprochement qui est fait est
que je trouve journalistique mans
inquiétant entre la pression qu'organise
qu'organise qu'orchestre certaines ong
auprès des pouvoirs publics pour
défendre des causes environnementales
sociales féministes etc et les grands
groupes les grandes multinationales qui
elles font effectivement du lobbying de
façon extrêmement professionnelle
extrêmement coûteuses en recourant aux
services de cabinets professionnels en
la matière mais pour défendre leurs
intérêts économiques
leurs intérêts privés leurs intérêts
particuliers qui peuvent bien souvent
aller à l'encontre de l'intérêt général
ou de l'intérêt des consommateurs
les ong anti nucléaires par exemple
elles défendent des intérêts oui alors
elles défendent des intérêts il me
semble qu'elle essaye de se situer les
unes et des autres
du côté encore une fois de ce que
pourrait être l'intérêt général le
féminisme est un lobbying encore une
fois est la cause écologiste a marché
avec le lobbying
je n'arrive pas à mettre en fait ces
combats là au même niveau que la défense
d'intérêts de multinationales comme les
grands groupes de l'agroalimentaire de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et les autres
c'est vrai que c'est un point de vue de
ce dossier qui consiste à s'intéresser à
tous les gens qui essaient de faire
avancer leur cause auprès des
responsables politiques autrement qu en
étant actif sur le lobby féministe il
n'y aurait pas eu la parité il n'y
aurait pas aujourd'hui une loi qui se
prépare en matière d'égalité
professionnelle d'égalité salariale
olivier ravanello inquiétante passé
lobby a déjà eu un problème sémantique
il me semble que vous en faites vous
finissez sous le mode lobby par dire
influence ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose
la perception du lobby
du moins en france elle est d'une
organisation assez structuré qui en
effet prendre la défense de grands
groupes industriels et en gros il ya
beaucoup d'argent derrière c'est ça un
lobby vous avez sans doute raison mon
point de vue d'élargir la réflexion est
ce qu'il faut garder le mot lobby pour
autant je ne sais pas mais ça va plus
loin que ça et de toute façon la
politique
les responsables politiques se
nourrissent d'expériences de terrain
individuel de gens qui sont dans des
secteurs d'activité et qui disent ben
moi je pense que l'abe devra les
dentelles sens parce que connaissant
bien mon secteur il faut plutôt que ça
aille dans ce sens là puis un autre qui
va dire non il faut aller dans ce sens
là parce que son entreprise va en
bénéficier mais aussi parce que c'est
une réalité du secteur qu'ils qu'il
connaît bien qui est du lobbying depuis
toujours qu'aujourd'hui se structure
dans des cabinets que vous décrivez dans
l'article c'est juste un changement de
forme
auparavant c'était le chef d'entreprise
lui-même qui prenait qui prenaient
rendez vous avec le premier ministre ou
président et qu'ils allaient défendre
ses intérêts là c'est une manière un peu
plus diffuse mais au final la question
qui se pose c'est toujours la même est
ce qu'un député peut faire la loi dans
une bulle je crois pas il a besoin de se
nourrir de ce qui se passe dans la
société et des expertises qui ne peuvent
pas venir simplement d'une expertise
universitaire ou ou technocratique
donc ça fait remonter de l'info le lobby
malgré tout le problème c'est au moment
de la prise de décision peut-être
faudrait-il imaginé un système plus
transparent avec une forme d'obligation
pour les lobbys de déclarer leurs
activités auprès de qui d'obligations de
mentionner des sommes engagées vacille
de plus en plus un c'est de plus en plus
mais voilà et au final peut-être mais je
sais pas c'est une idée qui m'est venue
comme ça en lisant votre papier de
sanctuariser l'exécutif qui en charge de
trancher dans l'intérêt public
mais que le rôle du représentant c'est
une représenté dans sa diversité et y
compris aussi ses secteurs d'activité là
on vous pose la question sur twitter
chers internautes
craignez-vous une influence des lobbys
sur les décisions du gouvernement et
vous êtes 84% à nous répondre oui
béarnais nous dit les lobbys il faut
découvrir l'eau chaude pour découvrir
aujourd'hui leur influence
et puis effectivement blueberry qui
défend des groupes de minorités qui
défendent exclusivement leurs intérêts
canadiens est ce que vous avez peur des
lobbys je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
fantasmes sur le lobbying et le sondage
le montre ici c'est à dire que un lobby
c'est tout et n'importe quoi un think
tank et un lobby j'imagine que en tant
que représentant d'une organisation qui
fait des propositions politiques
publiques vous allez voir des élus vous
allez voir des responsables politiques
d'administration pour proposer des
politiques publiques donc à partir du
moment où vous vous participez à la vie
politique vous fait pression pour telle
ou telle cause tel ou tel intérêt tel ou
tel politique publique vous êtes un
lobby un syndicat est un hobby une
congrégation religieuse peut être un
lobby une ong écolos peut-être peut-être
peut-être un lobby nommé de facto est
donc aujourd'hui effectivement le lobby
est consubstantielle à la politique je
pense pas qu'on puisse s'en débarrasser
là où moi j'ai une plus grande critique
vis-à-vis de l'activité de bing c'est
que elle révèle quand même dans une
certaine mesure une une incapacité à à
connaître l'année juste l'attribution de
la législation dans un pays où la loi
peut peut agir sur tout et n'importe
quoi peut régler toutes les affaires
forcément vous allez attirer des groupes
des groupes d'intérêts qui vont avoir
précisément a intérêt à faire pencher la
décision publique d'un côté ou un autre
donc si on veut vraiment réduire le
poids des des groupes d'intérêts dans la
vie politique
l'enjeu c'est à mon avis de réduire le
champ la sphère le champ pardon de
compétence de la législation ce qui
permettrait d'avoir des politiques vis
beaucoup plus transparentes que dans un
dur nous il ya une inflation législative
réglementaire ce qui attire tous les
groupes d'intérêt fait effectivement si
on laisse faire tout ce qu'on si on
voulait se faire aux groupes d'intérêts
tout ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
puisque la loi ne les en empêchera plus
fait qu'il y aura plus de l'aube il si
l'on peut vous en existe et ça c'est le
mon idée
dans les quelques nous proposait hier si
on laissait faire laisser aller complet
effectivement il ya plus de législation
interne mais il n'ya presque a
pratiquement publicisation un peu besoin
de vie pour essayer d'influencer leur
rôle et l'antarctique de judith à une
troupe pas étonnant de la part de 8 sur
trop qui est une habituée de la la
quelle je suis plus d'accord s'est lassé
de ses lacets entame
c'est à dire que ce qu'elle dit ce que
j'ai envie d'y apprendre c'est pas
puisque papier montre c'est que nous
avons franchi un pas historique dans la
place des lobbys en français à un moment
on a essayé de légiférer sur ce qu'était
un lobby l'obligation commencer à leur
mettre des déclarations pratiquement
pour la première fois dans les cinq
dernières années ont commencé à faire
des voix les initiations obligation de
déclaration à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat avait des limites passé d'ailleurs
parlé le biou même je voulais être
interrompue sur la sur les murs les sols
et les congrégations
il se trouve que les associations au
duomo catholiques sont intervenus pour
être exclu de la liste des lobbys et
pour une fois mal aller les législateurs
ont été d'accord puisque l'amendement a
été voté à l'assemblée nationale donc ça
prouve que le lobbyisme anti lobby et
ben ça marche bah ouais ce que je veux
dire c'est que là où le parent a été
franchie c'est qu'il est le les lobbys
sont maintenant au gouvernement pour la
première fois nous avons officiellement
un premier ministre dont dans le passé à
a fait la fonction de directeur des
affaires publiques d'areva directeur des
affaires publiques demandez à n'importe
quel cas d'une entreprise privée qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un lobby c'est le
personne qui est chargé d'aller
contacter les élus de la république pour
faire passer les messages de que
l'entreprise de leur pays n'est pas seul
à payer les tahitiens n'est pas celle
d'un gamin griveaux afellay exact même
chose porte parole du gouvernement
madame wargon qui vient de rentrer il a
fait la même chose chez john et son
plaisir
pour la première fois et là c'est vous
qui avez dit il faudrait sécurisé
exécutif vous avez bien raison mais il
fait il faut se dépêcher sert il faut
faire on se ferait en sorte de faire
sortir de l'exécutif le premier ministre
on peut le porte parole et plusieurs
ministres ils sont une petite dizaine à
voir et avoir été avoir défendu les
intérêts privés a commencé d'ailleurs
faut pas oublier le secrétaire de
général de l'elysée lui
voilà une professionnalisation de la vie
politique à outrance avec des morts on
va dire les choses simplement d'avoir
d'avoir des gens à voir des gens
insoupçonnable comme premier magistrat
de ce pays je pense que c'est un peu le
minimum qu'on peut demander si on veut
que l'arrêt de la démocratie continue à
être respectés dans ce pays je vous
signale qu'on discutait des gilet jaune
il ya juste cinq minutes que pensez vous
qu'ils pensent eux de la manière dont
ils sont gouvernés vous prévoyez pas le
mec parce que c'est bien de dire qu'on a
envie doit vous avez une alternative
c'est plus de règles ok je pense ne
serait pas suivie dans ce pays
mathieu ceux qui avaient su qu'un trio
qu'il connaît probablement le mieux le
monde ministériel puisque vous avez été
le collaborateur d'une ministre est-ce
que vous pensez que ce genre de risque
existe est ce que parce que dans le
passé un ministre a travaillé pour
défendre des intérêts d'une entreprise
il en est forcément encore prisonnier
une fois qu'il était effectivement
constaté que les lobbys existait était
puissant j'ai constaté qu'ils
intervenaient effectivement bien
davantage auprès des parlementaires
auprès du pouvoir législatif que du
pouvoir exécutif ce qui ne veut pas dire
que dans les ministères on ne reçoit pas
adhéré au fond n'est pas contacter marie
lobbyistes mais les décrets
d'application vous avez pas les levine
dans la lho mystère je ne dis pas qu'il
n'existe pas vous les jours raconte
l'histoire de ferrero comment ils ont
bloqué le décret d'application de
certains sèche vous étiez pas c'était
l'avant d'un pénis l'air gelé ailleurs
ferrero est intervenu ou les convoquera
compte c'était pas au moment de la loi
s'est enchaîné le crès je ne dis pas du
tout qu'il n'existe pas je dis que pour
ce que j'en est venu moi je pense que
j'en ai vu de ma fenêtre c'est que il
était d'autant plus actif auprès des
parlementaires et on sait que sur tout
un tas de textes on retrouve des
amendements qui sont rédigées par des
lobbyistes transmis au groupe
parlementaire de tout le tout
l'hémicycle et qu'on retrouve des
amendements déposés par le parti
communiste ou par l'est républicain qui
reprennent exactement les mêmes termes
voilà exactement je ne veux pas que vous
êtes là j'ai par ailleurs travaillé dans
le secteur de l'eau je peux vous dire
que les multinationales de l'eau ou les
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire les
grands minéraliers font oeuvre de
lobbying dans absolument tous les sens
non je suis d'accord avec vous hervé je
dis je je je note aussi cette ce qu'ils
auraient fait schizophrénie française
pardon qui veut que si les élites
politiques sont totalement étanche
vis-à-vis des élites économiques on leur
fait le reproche de ne rien qu'on
rendre au monde réel au monde économique
et puis si en revanche il ya des
passages de l'un à l'autre on se plaint
de la collusion entre ces deux pouvoirs
donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours
extrêmement compliqué que le lobbying
aujourd'hui et besoin d'être régulé et
de faire preuve de davantage de
transparence encore même si les choses
ont progressé au cours de ces cinq
dernières années ses réels posés un
sujet qui est presque un sujet de philo
le lobbying peut-il être moral et pour
avoir une illustration
je vous propose qu'on s'intéresse à un
monsieur dont on fait le portrait dans
ce dossier qui s'appelle thierry costes
qui accostent certains lobbies qui est
devenu célèbre le jour où nicolas hulot
en démissionnant a expliqué que comme
ministre des l'économie de l'écologie
pardon il avait été choqué de voir
thierry costes qui est le lobbyiste
officielle de la chasse en france
participer à une réunion à l'elysée
thierry costes s'occupe aussi d'un
certain nombre de d'état en tout cas de
gouvernement africains et ils l'assument
parfaitement
voilà ce qu'il en disait c'était en août
dernier chez nos confrères de rmc
quand je travaille avec un certain
nombre de gouvernements ils peuvent
avoir des problèmes divers et variés
avec les droits de l'homme quand on est
dans les pays d'afrique
marc fois désolé ça se passe pas
toujours très bien mais et alors c'est
pas mon problème moi je travaille sur
des sujets qui sont précis regardez par
exemple sur le tchad
incroyable le tchad mais pourquoi c'est
incroyable mais il faut assumer mais
vous avez oublié qu'il vaut mais en fait
je suis complètement mais ça fait 25 ans
que j'assume
voilà est-ce que ça vaut mieux 7,7 est
au moins au moins celui là il sait pas
un lobbyiste de l'ombre hervé nathan non
c'est pas une liste de lobbies de mon
bras lors sur la rue maufils de fix que
ce que je constate c'est je sois
mercenaire je suis mercenaires et
j'assume et c'est assez étonnant le
mollah le mot j'assume ou là le voka
enfin le verbe d'assumer en train de se
répandre communauté des poudres dans la
politique française
ça fait appel à la sanction qui est
quand même le fête du 15 août c'est
l'assomption de la vierge par le ciel
est d'une certaine manière ça
[Musique]
l'accord de la vierge était assumée par
dieu nous sommes 100 gagne si ça donc
c'est la sanction c'est la fête de
l'assomption et ses éléments c'était la
solution donnée par mariano figaro
salalah donc les certaine manière parce
que moment on dit j'assume surtout c'est
il ya plus de débat puisque voilà
j'assume donc circulez ya rien à voir il
ya discuté se trouve que c'est ça de
manière c'est la seule c'est là où on
voit la limite du débat public en ce
moment parce que le président aurait pu
en dire bien drapés dans la république
le premier ministre
tout le monde est dans la sanction alors
que nicolas hulot a fait une pub
remarquable à monsieur cost et que grâce
à nicolas hulot qu'il est devenu un des
lobbyistes les plus célèbres est en tout
cas connu du grand public désormais et
pour en revenir à votre sujet de philo
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut différencier
de mon point de vue de la morale que je
n'aime pas beaucoup puisque chacun a la
sienne et la critique est très
discutable de l'éthique l'éthique c'est
une série de règles conforme à une
activité pour qu'elle fonctionne bien et
on s'y tient et c'est les règles et on
les pose elles sont transparentes elles
sont connues de tous et on s'inscrit
dans cette éthique on laisse le dernier
mot à nos internautes
ça vous va aux béarnais qui nous dit de
lobbying peut-il être moral pour
l'interrogation réponse non car il
utilise ces méthodes en sous-marin
blueberry nous parle des institutions
européennes qui sont vérolées de lobby
et c'est vrai qu'on s'est plutôt
focalisés nous sur le les pouvoirs
publics français et babineau qui lui dit
des lobbies ne sont pas la société et
n'ont aucune légitimité
ils se désignent eux-mêmes et ben
écoutez voilà si ça vous si le sujet
vous intéresse vous savez ce que vous
pouvez lire ce week-end on va revenir à
emmanuel macron on a un peu parlé je
sais plus qui disait que il s'était
montré arrogant c'est devenu la dernière
dernier exercice à la mode inquiet de
critiquer le président de la république
à la fois les français quand il fait son
itinérance mémorial et qui le
le sollicite de façon assez assez direct
assez brutale et françois hollande aussi
s'y est mis il semble même y prendre
goût écouter l'ancien pression de la
république il était hier devant les
caméras de nos confrères de bfm tv
les français je pense que faut pas leur
faire elles sont il faut leur donner des
informations beaucoup d'informations et
des explications et comprendre la colère
quelquefois à nîmes le compatriote de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent comprendre ce
que l'on fait et aussi eu même avoir la
conviction que ceux qui dirigent les
observe les regarde et écoute
bon allez dire à loger près ce qu'on
veut dire que quand j'entends ça je vais
presque envie de défendre manuel macron
on parle de landes on parle de ma part
de ce qui vous voulez on parle de
manière d'un conte pour se demander si
cette critique n'est pas un peu
systématique compris venant de gens
comme françois hollande n'ont pas
forcément été des modèles de gouvernance
président si parce que moi ce qui me
dérange c'est pelé s'est passé pas de
macron cela irait prochaine c'est
justement ce ne sont pas des critiques
ce sont des débats des hystérisation de
micro problème et ce ne sont pas des
critiques sur ce qu'il fait sur ce qu'il
dit sur sa politique finit par ne plus
savoir ce qui en ce moment est votée au
parlement est ce que vous savez où un
mot non plus on est tous journalistes je
mets au défi c'est sa mère et j'ai
quelques chefs d'entreprise vous avez
raison mais heureusement la bêta mais
j'ai quelques chefs d'entreprises autour
de moi qui tous me disent mais cette loi
les fondamentale et structurante elle
est très important on s'en fout
royalement
en revanche la petite phrase de macron
et est-ce qu'il a bien fait d'aller sur
un porte-avions ou pas faire un
porte-avions et le tweet de l'elysée
alors là tout le monde a un avis ça
c'est problématique et ça ça ne regarde
tout ça sert à rien d'aller chercher des
explications à m mathieu souk ahras que
le maquereau bashing est trop
systématique alors je sais pas s'il est
systématique fin en tout cas on voit
bien que c'est une tendance dont macron
fait aujourd'hui les frais mais dont ses
prédécesseurs eux-mêmes ont fait les
frais et on voit bien que quel que soit
le nouveau président élu
il ya une posture assez simple en
général de la part d'un nouveau
président qui est de prendre l'exact
contre-pied de ce qu'a fait son
prédécesseur sarko a fait de l'anti
chirac
hollande a fait de l'anti sarko macron
fait de l'anti hollande et en général ça
paye un tout petit peu au début et
encore pas tellement est en tout cas
très rapidement tous tombent dans les
mêmes gouffre d'impopularité
le problème de l'impopularité et donc en
général des coupes d'une part qu'une
part de bashing
c'est que ça crée de l'impuissance dire
que on voit bien que l'opinion à des
attentes nourries des attentes
extrêmement forte vis-à-vis de ses
gouvernants peut-être que même que ses
attentes n'ont jamais été aussi forte
qu'aujourd'hui alors même que nous
gouvernent nos gouvernants semblent
disposer d'un pouvoir de plus en plus
relatifs de plus en plus relatif est
donc évidemment cette confrontation
entre des attentes très élevées et des
pouvoirs relatifs créer une très grande
insatisfaction l'opinion qui peut parce
qu'il ya aussi les réseaux sociaux dont
je parlais tout à l'heure
savoir tout tout le temps en temps réel
et le commenter donc gouverner a
longtemps était un art extrêmement
complexe j'ai le sentiment que gouverner
devient aujourd'hui un art totalement
impossible il ya quand même une
accélération et une amplification qui
est dû aux réseaux sociaux de ce bashing
par rapport à ce qu'on a connu il ya dix
ans et que le thème du bashing du jour
aujourd'hui fait l'objet d'articles pas
d'articles de fond c'est pas les
articles c'est pas les enquêtes que vous
publiez sur vos versions payantes non
c'est des articles plus courts qu'on va
mettre sur les sites gratuits ouverts et
qui donc vont être viraliser et vont
être lu par le plus grand nombre et
c'est ça qui nourrit le débat et ça
encore une fois on en est éminemment
responsable lorsqu'un création c'est que
les internautes sont très partagés 1
on leur a posé la question ceux qui
suivent cette émission avez vous
l'impression qu emmanuel macron est
critiqué de façon systématique 54%
répondu oui 46% répondent non et puis je
vous livre ses deux commentaire d'un
internaute qui a comme ceux de nîmes
réaliste nous aimons trop élire des
personnes que nous aimerons critiquer
ensuite et r34 qui nous dit notre
président est peut-être arrogant c'est
le qualificatif qu'on n'employait tout à
l'heure mais on ne peut pas nier qu'il
incarne mieux la fonction que ses deux
prédécesseurs saga nasillard et est ce
que il n'ya pas un parent de de
systématisme dans ce dans ce macron
bashing pour reprendre l'expression
je suis envie de dire que c'est de bonne
guerre il est chef de l'état il sait
qu'ils s'exposent à des critiques chaque
fois qu'il en parle moi c'est pas
vraiment ce qui m'intéresse c'est vrai
effectivement moi ce qui me dérange avec
les critiques concernant emmanuel macron
c'est que on se préoccupe peut-être un
petit peu trop de son style de la forme
que du fond à savoir son action
politique
alors que il ya matière à critiquer et
en matière d'action politique c'est à
dire que le candidat emmanuel macron a
quand même été élu sur un un discours
très descriptif en disant vous allez
voir vous allez voir ce pays moi je vais
vous changez de comptes en comptes
je vais je vais tout réformer et une
fois qu'il est au pouvoir on se rend
compte que finalement la disruption a un
peu disparu on est dans la continuité on
est dans dans l'immobilisme qui
caractérise la politique française
depuis jusqu'à l'usure dans la
continuité
si ces dépenses publiques qu'il a les
impôts ne bouge pas vous avez quelques
années parce que oui non il a transformé
en effet mais vous avez encore mal le
niveau général c'est-à-dire le l'agrégat
qui compte c'est celui ci le général des
voix on va parler à l'accueil mais ce
que je n'ai jamais baissé
il ya eu matière à baisser sur qui
accueille la matière il ya matière à
critiquer le fond de son action
politique qui à mon avis n'est pas
suffisamment critique et on accorde trop
d'importance au style donc c'est
peut-être là dessus qu'il faut davantage
disputer hervé nathan une certaine
manière le meilleur critique de l'e mail
mâcon c'est lui ça casse est étonnant
c'est que parce que certaines personnes
auxquelles mon père est très
intelligente donc en fait il réfléchit
beaucoup sur ce qui fait et pas du tout
il peut il par des mouvements d'humeur
mais il ya une chose de très important
mercredi soir
sur tf1 il a dit je n'ai pas réussi à
réconcilier les français avec leur
gouvernement
moi je trouve que c'est une phrase
absolument étonnante de la part d'un
président de la république
d'abord parce qu'il en parle au passé ça
veut dire que ça fait il aurait dit je
n'ai pas encore ça veut dire qu'il
espérait encore y arriver
mais voilà il l'a dit au passé d'une
certaine manière on a l'impression que
il le prend ça comme un [ __ ]
enfin comme une chose comme un invariant
on va dire pas comme un acquis non plus
c'est parce qu'ils cherchaient mais
comme un invariant et voilà c'est s'est
bloqué et j'y arriverai pas l'espèce de
constat d'impuissance et ça c'est très
important parce que juste à thème
manière c'était ça fait partie la
promesse de sa campagne c'était de faire
redémarrer le pays le réunifier l'envoyé
de langueux tout le monde grosso modo
nous emmener vers un avenir meilleur
c'était la promesse de sa compagne de
son élection
et ça c'est pour le coup ça vaut de ses
traits mais c'est vrai que ça a été peu
relevé s'était relevé quand même est
assez peu et qu'est ce que ça signifie
c'est d'une certaine manière c'est les
gilet jaune samedi vont peut-être nous
dire ce que c'est peut-être pas
d'ailleurs peut-être qu'il va rien se
passer
est-ce qu'en plus le pire on discutait
beaucoup mais peut-être qu'il y aura que
700 personnes dans la rue samedi est
très général de point de vue de nicole
qui nous dit comme macron passe son
temps à nous dénigrer
je ne vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas le bas chez olivier ravanello ya
cette idée qui serait un petit peu
responsable de ce qui lui arrive c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il admet lui-même
lorsque comme le disait hervé nathan à
l'instant il reconnaît qu' il n'a pas
réussi à combler ce lien il a ajouté
dans la même interview à tf1
les français veulent être respectés il
ya deux choses il ya évidemment cette
attitude là qu'on a qualifié de
jupitérienne cette façon qu'il a voulu
de re singulariser
la fonction présidentielle en étant plus
en hauteur en étant plus directif
parfois plus qu'à 100 pour pour faire
bouger les choses et pour envoyer des
messages mais aussi parce que c'est dans
son caractère et c'est comme ça qu'il
s'exprime le corollaire tu ça aussi
c'est qu'il est tellement seul que c'est
lui qui prend tout il prend tout parce
qu'il ya personne autour de lui pour
défendre un moindre mesure on est sur
une mobilisation sur les jets les jaunes
qui à la base est quand même une
mobilisation autour de problématiques
qui touchent l'écologie ceni de rigide
et une portion qui sont capables de
monter au créneau pour lui personne ne
peut monter au créneau à part lui vous
avez en permanence son porte parole qui
va quasiment tous les jours pour essayer
d'éteindre un incendie et vous avez un
premier ministre qui manifestement n'a
pas donné de bon de sortie pour en faire
un peu plus donc c'est aussi le résultat
de cette façon qu'il a de de concentrer
l'exercice de la politique autour de lui
qui est très positive quand ça
fonctionne avec les gens votent pour
vous et quand ça revient c'est encore
une fois il ya pas de fille a pas
d'intermédiaire parce qu'il pense qu'il
est seul parce que ça reste un mouvement
incarné dirigé porté par emmanuel macron
mais qui au tour a toujours passé
émerger de pointu entre les choses ne
furent pas si différente que ça encore
une fois sous ses prédécesseurs et on
voit bien que les types de l'opinion
fonctionne comme un rabot et que
l'étiage des sondages qu'il touche
aujourd'hui est exactement l olympique
vous n'avez pas comparer valsa castaner
vous allez pas comparer fabius
le drian enfin encore une fois je n'ai
pas pour pour pour cautionner la
politique qui a pu être mené mais
simplement en termes d'épaisseur
politique c'est-à-dire être capable de
gérer une crise être capable de
communiquer de ne pas faire un pas de
travers d'avoir une crédibilité dans la
parole politique que vous portez
aujourd'hui y'a rien autour
non mais l'entourage que dont sarkozy
pouvait disposer ou hollande etc ne les
ont pas empêchés en termes de popularité
de jeu de rallye c'est de glisser très
rapidement vis-à-vis de l'opinion on
peut arrêter ça mathus au caire dont
joseph avec françois hollande
pas de discussion le bashing
présidentielle avec françois on s'est
aperçus qu une fois que c'était parti
ça a duré tout le reste du quinquennat
alors de ce point de vue là emmanuel
macron alors je sais pas si c'est une
question de talent ou de houe de chance
mais emmanuel macron a été davantage
épargnée
on se souvient que françois hollande a
amorcé son quinquennat avec une première
journée qui avait été un peu rude pour
lui dès le premier jour de la passation
de pouvoir une polémique née parce
qu'ils ne restent pas suffisamment
longtemps sur le perron de l'elysée et
qu'il ne fait pas les bons gestes pour
accompagner son prédécesseur il enchaîne
ensuite en se prenant la pluie sur les
champs-elysées et tout le monde se
gausse de cette séquence
et puis le soir la journée se termine
mal il prend l'avion il prend la foudre
on va voir merkel pas du tout aucunement
j'imagine que ça allait un peu pour
françois hollande mais que peut être que
ça explique pour partie ces déclarations
d'aujourd'hui a besoin de plonger le
truc mais on se souvient que le holland
bashing a marché très vite et très fort
et que les hebdos ont fait leur une dès
le mois de juin 2012 sur hollande de
façon si ce n'est ironique parfois même
insultantes et que les ventes étaient au
rendez vous donc encore une fois c'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau et de
synthétiser dans un livre absolument un
excellent livre dont je recommande la
lecture à tous ceux qui ont aimé le
quinquennat de consolider tous ceux qui
ne l'ont pas aimé ça devrait faire du
monde
en tout état de cause à partir du moment
où il y a des attentes dans l'opinion en
matière de résultats et de résultats
économiques et sociaux et où ces
résultats peinent à arriver parce que la
politique c'est pas du tout court
en fait la politique ça s'inscrit dans
la durée et je ne dis pas ça ni pour
défendre aujourd'hui macro ni pour
défendre hier hollande la politique
c'est du temps long or le temps
politique s'est accéléré le quinquennat
a raccourci le temps politique et les
attentes de l'opinion encore une fois ce
sont elles même accentuée c'est de plus
en plus difficile de faire converger les
deux ok ben voilà un message pour le
président de la république on passe à un
dernier sujet le monde entier connaît
désormais portrait d'un artiste piscine
avec deux personnages c'est un tableau
du peintre britannique david hockney qui
date de 1972 et qui est à ce jour le
tableau le plus cher du monde
en tout cas pour un peintre vivant
puisqu'il a été vendu cette semaine par
christie's à new york
90 millions de dollars c'est à dire
environ 80 millions d'euros ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que ce mouvement
d'inflation et générale il ya eu 80 ans
cette semaine
à new york organisé par trois grandes
maisons christie's sotheby's et et
philips vente d'art d'après guerre et
contemporain et elles ont réalisé
ensemble plus d'un milliard de dollars
de ventes
est ce que tout ça est complètement fou
olivier ravanello est-ce que acheter un
tableau 90 millions de dollars
ça vous paraît après tout plutôt amusant
ou complètement symbolique d'un
dérèglement de notre société à g aucun
jugement moral là dessus pour moi l'art
n'a intrinsèquement pas une valeur qui
se mesure par une somme sinon ça
voudrait dire que au moment où picasso
peint un tableau il a un prix qui est le
même cent ans plus tard voilà je vous
interromps une seconde ce tableau avait
été vendu par oc n'est lui-même en 1972
vingt mille dollars
c'est à dire quatre mille cinq cent fois
moins cher qu il a été vendu cette
semaine
et au moment où il a vendu il ya sans
doute des gens qui les 20000 dollars
mais c'est beaucoup trop cher pour ce
truc ça les vaut pas donc voilà c'est un
débat qui pour moi est est sans objet
après l'art est un marché moitié des
piscines ou plus et en plus de ça il ya
un autre bouquet parce que c'est un
marché donc c'est un marché il ya une
offre il ya une demande de très très
loin je mens je préfère à la limite que
des gens s'emballent pour une oeuvre
d'art que pour d'autres produits
beaucoup plus mercantiles et futile
tombe mieux après tout parce que quand
on les possèdent et qu'on les achète
aussi cher c'est à dire qu'on va les
conserver c'est votre avis mais nathan
toute façon il n'y a pas de sujet c'est
le journal fait de ce prix là et puis
c'est comme ça c'était un marché cf le
market non c'est un marché libre
limite c'est presque un marché pur en
théorie alors ça n'allait pas du tout
parce qu'en fait on sait très bien que
les codes ça se fabrique mais alors
aucune a un vrai talent là le tableau
est magnifique et d'une certaine manière
là où on voit que c'est un vrai talent
c'est qu'il ya eu 6 158 visiteurs pour
l'exposition hockney à beaubourg et moi
j'en étais c'était si on n'avait pas pu
faire ça mais oui ça m'a plu c'est parce
que je préfère nolan dans l'armée ça m'a
plu quand même donc il y avait des gens
il y avait de l'émotion
et c'est à ça que ça se voit que 6e
quand ça marche c'est quand il ya une
émotion devant leur devant devant devant
une oeuvre maintenant et tout une autre
partie au cne on va pas en discuter
parce que c'est un peu un indiscutable
comme qualités mais il y en a d'autres
salles et moi qui font mal assez
discutable voilà alors ça c'est
typiquement suis attentive à la merci
merci d'abord 47 millions d'euros en
et ça ça se déclinant sous produit il
faut savoir c'est que vous pouvez
l'acheter en tout petit en très grand et
caetera et qu'en fait c'est pas c'est
pas de l'art coincé de ces de la ccc la
copie cdc du marketing c'est la
duplication etc c'est voilà ci ont donc
par exemple - j'ai reçu il ya quelques
années pas très longtemps je suis allé à
florence sur la place de la seigneurie
la cie la place de l'année assignera il
ya le david de michel-ange tout le monde
sait ça enfin digne des plus belles
chansons entre autres est à tous publics
et puis il y avait une statue de koons
un truc doré comme ça alors c'était une
copine
c'était une copie tout doré s'est du
coup c'est forcément tout doré et
c'était juste à côté du david de
michel-ange exposés comme ça la vue de
tous en fait j'ai compris après le
manque d'enseignants qu'en fait la
statue était à vendre
c'est à dire qu'on avait réussi à
obtenir de la municipalité de florence
l'autorisation d'exposer dans un endroit
absolument extraordinaire pour faire
monter la cote parce qu'être exposé à
côté de michel-ange
ça permet ensuite demandé des prix
absolument extraordinaire et c'est comme
ça que font une partie voilà une partie
du marché de l'art c'est ça aussi coin
ce qu'on a vu aussi au château de
versailles
et si mathieu sociaux qui assurera les
tulipes les tulipes qu'on nous les
tulipes il a donné juste certains en
disent que nous sommes pas loin de
l'anniversaire du 10 septembre du très
savants serait mis à sac du 13 novembre
on sait que jeff koons a fait don d'un
bouquet de tulipes à la ville de paris
pour honorer les victimes en fait il
avait donné le droit de la reproduire
c'est ensuite il va le voir construire
en béton les peindre
selon justin dessins de course alors on
doit reparler loin de quoi ils sont
aujourd'hui que deux retraits mathus ou
qu'est-ce que ça vous choque ou pas ça
une somme pareille pour un tableau je
rentrerai pas dans le match kunz contre
1 contre huk n'est j'aurais eu 90
millions d'euros j'aurais peut-être
acheté cette toile elle est
effectivement très belle je trouve que
j'avais pas 90 millions d'euros
donc j'ai fait autre chose hier mais
ouais ça arrive on verra la prochaine
fois c'est un très beau tableau alors
sais pas si ça me choque mais
effectivement on parlait de l'oeuvre de
queens de coutelas l'instant qui coûtait
45 ou 50 millions on dit que c'est un
peu comme dans le foot en fait à chaque
fois on fait foi de on a une espèce des
spéculations qui alors dans le foot les
sommes choc
dans l'art peut-être qu'elle choque
moins quand même parce qu'on parle on
parle de culture et en même temps on
voit bien qu'on a une petite difficulté
l'arrêt par principe désintéressée on
veut qu'on rêve d'un art pur on rêve de
l'artiste maudit et on a du mal à
imaginer qu'un artiste surtout de son
vivant soit riche et puissent vivre
aussi grâce monde sont à alors ils
trouvent que l'art est un marché c'est
ce que disait hervé à l'instant personne
ne le nie il se trouve que c'est un
marché qui se porte très bien
men même quand globalement l'économie ne
va pas si bien que ça ça dit quelque
chose probablement aussi de la
répartition de la richesse de l'art
moderne et contemporain parce que c'est
moins évident pour l'art du xviiie ou
pour des choses plus classiques souvent
de boxe ça se vend cher où l'on est donc
non on voit bien qu'on a un marché de
l'art qui se porte très bien et par
ailleurs ce n'est pas une nouveauté
puisque dans l'histoire les artistes ont
souvent été quand même du côté du
pouvoir il a fallu que des papes
commandes des fresques aux commandes des
statuts il a fallu que des rois commande
des portraits et donc en général on a eu
à toutes les époques des artistes qui
est un proche du pouvoir et répondant
aux commandes du pouvoir se sont assez
significativement enrichi dans leur vie
d'artiste on vous a posé la question sur
sur twitter êtes vous étonné par le prix
records du tableau de david hockney vous
répondez oui à 58% donc c'est
relativement balancer et a34 nous dit
ventoux placements financiers
là on n'a rien à voir là dedans et puis
c'est de ce commentaire aussi de deux
dents l'internaute qui le dit pour ce
prix
combien de bouche pour que nourrir trois
petits points ferghana et vous aurez le
mot de la fin
elle a évolué sur ce sujet et sur les
missions pour le coup si j'avais 90
millions de la deux
de dollars je n'aurais sans doute pas
acheté ce tableau donc comme quoi donc
ça c'est assez subjectif c'est vrai que
moi sont des sommes que je ne comprends
pas mais en même temps ça c'est
fascinant pour moi c'est marché de l'art
est quand même assez a des vertus assez
pédagogique sur le fonctionnement de ce
qu'est l'économie le système de
formation des prix qu'est ce qui fait
que les prix se forme c'est la
subjectivité tout simplement de les
préférences des gens qui font qu'ils
sont prêts à débourser 90 millions de
dollars pour pour une toile bon moi je
n'aurais pas fait ça je regarde mon avis
autre chose que de plus utile qu'à
acheter un tableau comme celui ci mais
bon si certains valeurs unis mais sauf
peut-être pour le revendre plus cher
peut-être que là j'aurais été dépensé
quelque 1,7 et l'avait pris pour un
kamikaze
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre bon week-end
à tous bonne manifestation saga nazis
arrêt n'oubliez pas votre gilet jaune et
nous on se retrouvera lundi probablement
pour débriefer en troll c'est cette
journée de samedi est à suivre
voilà la manifestation des gilet jaune
tout ce week-end sur figaro live merci
beaucoup et bon week-end
[Musique]